[Music]
the be active education award celebrates
exemplary initiatives encouraging kids
to be active in and out of the school
environment
despite the pandemic induced challenges
munich-based sports club tsv neurid evie
came up with a fantastic idea to get
kids to move that made them worthy
winners of the 2021 be active education
award during the times of homeschooling
and reduced school sports tsv neuris
created the sport and garden sound
concept the idea was simple the club's
trainers would visit young members at
their homes to do sports over their
garden fence
kids and parents could set an
appointment for a trainer to come to
their homes for free the trainers would
bring all the equipment needed to play
various sports and engage in physical
exercise together with the kids
not only did this give the kids a break
from being in front of their electronic
devices motivating them to go outside it
also allowed them to spend time with
their favorite trainers
they could even compete against their
trainers in the neurida vet camp
competitions of neurate win small prizes
and earn a certificate what's more kids
living nearby in the neighborhood often
joined in or were invited to join making
it a community experience
the social impact of our project i think
was that we could stay active and that
we could keep our members active
everyone was closed up in their homes
and can go outside and do sports
together so it was also a socializing
event